ça commence à être pas mal clair que la
situation allait
était si urgentes avait un une
préoccupation que ça pourrait se sentir
dégringoler encore plus ailleurs qui
avait une urgence d'agir et que
l'outil qu'on avait pour amener
rapidement
ces outils spécifiques
c'était la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence
juste un truc au vendredi sur la
réflexion de son gouvernement dans les
jours qui ont précédé l'invocation de la
Loi sur les mesures d'urgence le Premier
ministre 7 de ces ministres et certains
proches collaborateurs étaient à la
barre des témoins pour la dernière
semaine de travaux de la commission
rouleau ont-ils réussi à justifier
l'utilisation de cette mesure
exceptionnelle voyons voir ce qu'on
pense mes collaborateurs avec qui est
absent cette semaine c'est Madeleine
blémorin qui est avec nous les chefs du
bureau politique de Radio-Canada à
Ottawa Chantal Hébert et chroniqueur au
Toronto Star et au magazine L'actualité
Michel serroger chroniqueur politique à
la presse plus la Radio-Canada bonjour à
vous trois bonjour bonjour
Qu'est-ce que vous avez retenu du
témoignage du Premier ministre vendredi
une défense assez solide de la raison
pour laquelle il a invoqué la loi sur
mesure d'urgence et pour ceux qui aiment
la politique littéralement un cours de
sciences politiques de comment une
décision se prend au gouvernement
fédéral il a pris beaucoup de temps et
très rigoureux là-dessus on a parlé au
coquelus on a parlé à la haute fonction
publique on a parlé aux provinces et
expliqua à chaque fois qu'ils étaient
les étapes c'est comme à l'intérieur le
miroir c'est intéressant pour nous en
tout cas parce qu'on a rarement accès à
ça mais je pense que le but recherché
était d'expliquer ce qu'il a fait et de
dire voici pourquoi on a déjà arrivé à
cette conclusion là et on le fait en
faisant toutes les bonnes étapes et si
c'est ça le critère je pense qu'il est
assez bien justifié oui le recours à la
loi c'est vrai qu'il y avait du détail
Chantal
bon la question ont-ils réussi on va
avoir la réponse à février
et ce sont pas faites de tort et là
j'inclus les ministres qui ont précédé
Justin Trudeau et on présentait leur
cause et sans s'enferger les uns dans
les autres
ça faisait des changements on ne voit
pas souvent
Justin Trudeau qui parle sans note
vraiment le Sentex et qui passe pas son
temps à répéter des lignes cela dit ce
qu'il y avait aussi l'unique qui était
vraiment intéressante c'est l'idée qu'on
a en temps réel accès aux transcriptions
des conversations téléphoniques entre le
premier ministre du Canada la
gouvernance générale le Premier ministre
l'Ontario donc il fallait que Monsieur
Trudeau réconcilie son argumentaire avec
ce qui avait dit dans des conversations
privées avec toutes sortes
d'interlocuteurs d'abord on n'a jamais
accès à ces choses-là c'est jamais
arrivé oui pas le matin devant la
commission Gomery mais on n'avait pas ce
genre de matériel là et deuxièmement il
s'en est assez bien tiré là-dessus mon
plus gros bémol sur cette semaine c'est
que quelque part le gouvernement de
Monsieur Trudeau pas par la voix du
Premier ministre mais par celle de la
ministre des Finances avance l'argument
qu'on doit élargir les critères qui
définissent une menace à la sécurité
nationale pour inclure les menaces
économiques ça me semble au beau mot une
pente un peu savonneuse dans la mesure
où à partir de ce moment-là où est-ce
qu'on met la ligne quand il y a un
blocus ferroviaire autochtone quand il y
a une protestation écologique et si
j'étais parti conservateur qui parle pas
fort
j'aurais pris des notes de ce côté-là de
l'argumentaire en disant si un jour on
est au pouvoir
on pourrait réentendre certaines des
citations de cette semaine
qu'est-ce que vous avez retenu
il va parler de l'argumentaire
économique en disant c'était une
préoccupation mais c'était pas la raison
numéro 1 d'invoquer la loi la raison
numéro 1 c'était des menaces de violence
en parlant par exemple des armes qui ont
été découvertes en Alberta en parlant
des camions qui peuvent être utilisés
comme à en parlant de boucliers humains
d'enfants dans les camions qui servaient
de boucliers humains est-ce que ça ça
représente véritablement une menace de
violence suffisante pour invoquer la loi
je suis pas avocate et je suis pas
policière donc j'imagine effectivement
que le juge rouleau à la délicatache de
le déterminer mais politiquement Justin
Trudeau ne pas commis de gaffe qui
ferait changer l'opinion publique et on
l'a vu quand même assez sereins on l'a
vu souriant parfois on l'a vu assez
calme et j'ai l'impression parce qu'il
peut s'appuyer sur l'opinion publique
qui était généralement finalement en
faveur aux deux tiers des Canadiens là
qui était plutôt favorable ou favorable
à l'invocation de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence donc cette commission là elle
va pas trouver quelqu'un de coupable
elle va pas elle va pas mettre quelqu'un
à l'amende non plus le risque il est
politique et je pense pas que la
performance que Justin Trudeau a fait va
faire changer l'opinion publique dans ce
sens chacun je reviens à vous sur
l'ensemble de son travail parce que là
c'est terminé les témoignages là on a
entendu tout le monde est-ce que la
Commission a rendu a fait le travail
qu'elle devait faire dans le contexte de
la loi est-ce qu'on a l'impression
d'avoir fait ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'on a fait le tour qu'on
a entendu tous les intervenants qu'on a
en main ce qu'il faut pour rendre une
peau pour tirer des conclusions
en tout cas on a entendu à peu près tous
ceux qui avaient besoin de se faire
entendre
certains vont dire on n'a pas la vie
juridique sur lequel c'est appuyer le
gouvernement pour finalement décider que
c'était légal c'est protégé par la
relation
entre les clients je sais pas convaincu
moins que cet avis juridique là d'abord
était noir ou blanc parce que ce genre
de choses que tendance à aller dans des
zones grises vous pouvez le faire c'est
sans doute correct mais ça va
probablement contester ça ressemble
souvent à ça mais d'autre part je suis
pas sûr non plus que c'est cette habits
juridiques qui du coup a fait pencher la
balance je pense qu'il y avait tellement
de facteurs qui sont entrés en ligne de
compte que c'est un des éléments parmi
plusieurs ce qu'on saura jamais c'est si
la vie juridique disait vous pouvez pas
aller là vous allez pas réussir
le patron du renseignement dit selon
nous ça satisfaisait pas aux critères
d'abord je pense que c'est Madeleine qui
l'a dit il y a deux tiers des Canadiens
qui sont d'accord avec l'imposition de
la loi et il peut probable que ce qui
s'est passé comme sur nous les faits
changer d'idées alors dans la dans le
tribunal de l'opinion publique comme on
dit souvent je pense que je te donne son
permis l'autre chose c'est je crois pas
qu'on peut s'attendre à ce que je veux
d'autres devant des témoignages qui ont
entendu dire c'était absolument
inconstitutionnel inconsidéré c'était
pas la manière d'appliquer cette loi là
ça peut tout sa première fois qu'on
l'applique sa première fois aussi qu'il
y a
une exercice qu'on fait après
l'application de la loi pour voir si
c'était justifié donc je pense pas moi
que ça ça va nuire beaucoup au
gouvernement actuellement parce que de
toute manière on regarde tout a été fait
dans les règles tout a été fait de la
façon la plus rigoureuse possible selon
les témoignages qu'on a vu et à cause de
ça
ça devrait permettre au gouvernement de
s'en sortir assez facilement
Madeleine
et sentir mieux que d'autres parce que
souvenez-vous
eren auto dont on n'a pas parlé depuis
longtemps l'ancien chef conservateur
ce qu'on voit là lui en particulier son
poste le chef de police de taïwa est
parti en raison du convoi la commissaire
de la GRC sont leadership et fragilisé à
cause du convoi donc quand on considère
tout ça Justin Trudeau sentir vraiment
pas trop mal on fait un sort au Québec
maintenant parce que on se prépare pour
la rentrée parlementaire mardi après
deux mois après presque deux mois après
le scrutin je commence avec vous Michel
à quoi est-ce qu'on s'attend de cette
rentrée parlementaire courte séance
quand même mais quels sont vos attentes
par rapport à ce que ça donne
c'est une courte session littéralement
pour passer des projets de globes
budgétaires et ce genre là donc il y
aura pas grand chose qui ce qui est
intéressant à surveiller c'est la
nouvelle configuration de l'opposition
il y a 90 députés du parti au pouvoir
sans dispo beaucoup pour quatre parties
dont trois vont être représentés à la
Chambre qui ont eu à peu près 15 %
chacun le Parti québécois était celui
qui était vraiment en demande là-dedans
il semble que ça c'est réglé avec deux
questions par semaine puis un poste de
chef pour les appeler
comme toujours le règlement d'assemblée
nationale est très stricte et à chaque
fois qu'il y a un parti qui ne réussit
pas à avoir la norme soit de 20% soit de
12 députés qui est la norme à Québec on
fait des accordements nationales on a
toujours fait alors mais on va voir
comment cette opposition là qui est
quand même un peu étrange le PQ qui
était parti avec trois députés a eu plus
de votes que l'opposition officielle
libérale qui avait 21
c'est quand même assez déséquilibré
faudra voir comment chacun se positionne
là-dedans Québec sanitaire aimerait ça
se considérer comme la vraie opposition
on va voir si c'est possible on va voir
ce que le PNQ dans l'état où il est peut
faire comme opposition officielle en
même temps qu'une consolidation parce
que c'est toujours compliqué de jouer
les deux les yeux vont être plus tournés
dans cette session là vers l'opposition
vers le gouvernement et le gouvernement
lui a quelques projets de loi à faire
passer c'est pas la c'est pas la le
travail parlementaire qui va dominer
l'opposition officielle avait 21 siège
en reste 19 en Dominique englade et puis
là Marie-Claude Nicole veut pas encore
réintégré le caucus donc là je pense que
le défi est surtout justement sur
l'opposition officielle
martanguay c'est un bon dépatteur il va
être il va devoir prouver qui est
capable d'être un chef parce que jusqu'à
maintenant il y a pas de nécessairement
briller là quand on a parlé par exemple
de Marie-Claude Nicole justement ou bien
de épisode du Protecteur du citoyen
lorsque bon il y avait été vite sur la
gâchette pour dénoncer le manque
d’éthique du gouvernement avant de
savoir que c'était finalement un
ministre un ancien ministre libéralisé
donc il y a un adage qui dit par les en
bien par les en mal mais par les anges
et comme l'impression que pour le Parti
libéral ça va faire du bien si on
réussit à parler d'eux en bien et le
fait d'avoir devant eux un adversaire de
l'autre côté du salon bleu ça va aider
ça va aider à ne plus nécessairement à
être tout seul à se lancer des grenades
dans leur propre chaloupe mais
je pense que c'est eux d'abord et avant
tout que je vais observer là dans les
premières journées de la reprise des
traces
conservateurs parce qu'on en a une
collection à Ottawa pour témoigner de ce
que est un chef intégré c'est parfois
plus difficile au niveau de la gestion
du caucus pendant
la prestation à la période des questions
ou effectivement c'est bien d'avoir un
adversaire cela dit moi je pense pas
qu'on peut juger ou qu'on va prendre la
pleine mesure de la nouvelle Assemblée
nationale en plein temps et la fin de
l'année c'est vraiment une apparition
très très brève et ça va se corser ou
pas au printemps quand le budget va
arriver quand on va voir où on en est
sur le front de la récession la santé
mais j'ai comme l'impression qu'il y a
personne qui est d'humeur à faire de la
cette petite tranche de début de mandat
le moment où on fixe l'image et on dit
voilà de quoi ça
Gabriel nous a du bois cette semaine
disons encadré nos affaires un peu on va
parler davantage de d'économie puis de
lutte contre l'inflation on dirait qu'il
essaye d'occuper du terrain que devrait
occuper normalement les libéraux c'est
comme ça qu'on devrait le voir
c'est ce qu'il est là en tout cas ils
estiment que le parti libérale va être
occupé par tellement de choses d'abord
les débats internes ensuite le lit de
chips que c'est eux qui ont une chance
de briller cela dit c'est pas évident
c'est quand on regarde le nombre de
questions à l'Assemblée nationale et
tout ça c'est pas toujours facile à être
le deuxième comme ça mais c'est en fait
que ça donne une ouverture de montrer
qu'ils sont pas partis une équipe avec
juste quelques idées mais qui sont
capables de parler d'inflation qui sont
capables de parler de ces choses là
c'est vrai que c'est ils vont être à
surveillés au cours de cette petite
session là mais encore une fois le le
vrai spectacle commence à commencer à la
rentrée au printemps là ce sera pas
aujourd'hui c'est la répétition générale
ouais j'entends rapidement mais on
s'entend la tête des gens qui regardent
ce sera pas là-dedans
des fêtes ça c'est comme de penser que
tout le monde a arrêté de regarder la
Coupe du Monde cette semaine pour
regarder la commission
le temps de ces événements-là moi je
regarde la rentrée
d'après les fêtes comme le moment où ça
va être le vrai de
départs cette semaine la commission
rouleau la Coupe du monde alors
on donnera pas de nom mais effectivement
j'en ai vu quelques-uns Madeleine
Chantal Michel merci beaucoup à la
semaine prochaine au revoir au revoir